[Music]
hello
you guys how's the audio doing hopefully
it's fine
yeah you moved the thing all right
moving this so
somebody let me because you know the
microphone keeps like turning itself up
and
blah blah blah but it's it's been okay
it turned itself
up yesterday but that was the last time
it did it yeah so sound should be good
i hope so no one says anything so
no one said anything yeah all right so
we saw close encounters and saw red dawn
last night
yeah yeah i got we tried to watch that
other one
that somebody sent us from yeah okay
liam sent it
he's one of our patrons right we went to
go pop that thing in and they said uh
region b can't watch it in the u.s uk
only unless you have a region free
player
which i don't think we have one anywhere
so what i'll do is uh we'll stream it
and watch it
yeah yeah that'll work too yeah okay i
don't know like
i don't i wonder if the blu-ray player
in the living room is region free i can
check
yeah we should probably check it on that
before because we usually play things in
the xbox
yeah and as far as i know that doesn't
that's not region-free okay yeah
said i can hear you both fine okay
that's good all right that's good that's
good
so yeah tom had uh ordered a couple of
movies that he'd been wanting for a long
time close encounters of third kind
one of his favorite steven spielberg
movies yeah if not your favorite
stephensville
steven spielberg movie is it no no
no no that would be raiders of lost ark
right
yeah yeah i'm i'm torn between raiders
of the lost ark and jaws
so yeah probably those are probably my
two favorites gotta see jaws again too
haven't seen i want to get like a deluxe
issue of jaws you should they probably
got some nice
uh steel book and [ __ ] like that right
and then um i'm a big john millies fan i
haven't seen
i haven't seen red dawn in a while i
want to see how it aged
it aged i must put in a good age
it it's it had a good story we'll get to
it when the time comes though
yeah because kind of let's talk about
close encounters first because that was
the first first one that we watched
now okay so which version do we watch
because there's three different versions
we watched we watched the directors we
watched the director's cut
okay there's because there's also a
special edition
special edition has all the interior
shots of what they see when they go
inside the damn ufo
yeah and actually steven spielberg
didn't like that that's why he took it
out again
because that that was something that the
um the studio wanted
yeah i've seen both versions i actually
like the ones where you can see
he goes inside and sees everything yeah
it just looks like a bright city
you know there's there's nothing really
all that impressive about it by today's
standards
you see if i had i seen it it's what i
kind of wanted to see when i was a kid
yeah he walked in you know like wow what
did he say oh they [ __ ] us
over but i did like to i did like the
movie when i was a kid
it had a lot of the the pace of the
movie is a lot faster than i remembered
it's got a very quick pace it's got a
really good cast
fantastic dialogue even the little kids
the [ __ ] the little kids say
you're [ __ ] hilarious can we throw
dirt in our bedroom when you're
after you're done you know just [ __ ] the
kids would say
[Laughter]
and um actually throw it through the
window
because that's what daddy was doing yeah
so you know he's like well it must be
okay for us to do too
yeah and then like uh it's just funny
it's good it's good movie um a lot of
the stuff
from this is what 77 77 yeah a lot of
stuff from 77
which seemed mysterious and like badass
back in 77 is now a meme
like ufologists yeah they got the movie
shows ufologists in a [ __ ] very like
high on the [ __ ] totem pole like you
know
governments talk to them and [ __ ] you
know what i mean the u.n talks to
ufologists and they have a whole program
to contact extraterrestrials and
dudes in red jumpsuits that are ready to
go aboard [ __ ] flying saucers and get
the [ __ ] out of here you know cultural
exchange and everything
[ __ ] super computers made to talk to
[ __ ] ufos
it's cool it's quite cool i liked it i
like the movie
uh richard dreyfuss is in it and uh
dreyfus was like he was like the
ultimate every man
back in the 70s i mean that's the way a
lot of [ __ ] just everyday dudes are
like that
you know a lot of them well it's it's
it's funny because originally i mean
steven spielberg had been wanting to
make this movie since like the early 70s
now initially he wanted to make it as a
documentary because he was really
interested in
ufos and stuff yeah and uh he wanted to
make a documentary
and then he was like no like you know
what i'm imagining is gonna be
like a lot more expensive than a
documentary so i have to make it into a
feature film
but i guess he pitched it to a couple
studios and he wasn't like a real big
famous he'd made a couple movies by that
time but he wasn't like you know super
famous or anything
so they were just kind of like yeah no
we'll pass um
so he kind of went through a few
different iterations of it like there
was one that i think was called
watch the skies um there was one that
was written by somebody else and i can't
remember what it was called now but
it was a different thing and originally
some of the other iterations of the
script
which were not necessarily written by
him
i think the first one was like supposed
to be about an army guy
that was a debunker of ufos
but then he saw one and then he
like him and he went to the government
is like yeah we have to find the you
know ufos and like trying to contact
them
and then the next iteration the guy like
the main character was a cop
but then steven spielberg was like i
think it would be better if it was just
like a regular dude
that you know just like in every man
like you said
that has an encounter and it like
changes the and also he kind of wanted
to do something
with because there's a lot of like
themes in this
movie and like watching it again it
became a lot clearer to me like what
the themes of it are like what are you
talking about well one there's a big
like kind of judeo-christian
kind of thing like not in an overt way
but there's a lot of parallels
to like a jesus story moses story stuff
like that
and um something that he goes into a lot
is communication you know what i mean
um because something that i really
noticed a lot on this watching of it
was that in almost every scene
particularly from the beginning of the
movie
there's um people either talking at the
same time or they're talking across
purposes or they're talking
in different languages that have to be
like retranslated you know for one
another
and then like as the movie goes on like
when the aliens come
like everybody um is kind of like
in agreement or everybody can understand
one another because the aliens are
talking to us through
music which is a universal language so
i think that he was kind of going for
and actually i think he said this also
in
interviews and stuff that that was kind
of like
one thing that he was kind of going for
in this and why there were why the
why the opening scene was like i got one
guy speaking english one guy speaking
spanish one guy speaking french and they
were having to like translate everything
back and forth there was all this
constant noise in the background yeah to
me that worked as a kid yeah yeah yeah
it made that made the whole story seem
like i had a much larger scope than just
a local event
yeah that this is this is a global type
of
event
it was like mankind's awakening to a
larger truth outside the planet
and and having all those languages
bounce off you when you were a kid
it added to the coolness and the and the
tempo of the movie
it seems like it's moving very fast and
i like that
it doesn't it doesn't ever it doesn't
really flounder
you know what i mean yeah or you don't
know what i'm talking about yeah yeah
yeah
the the edit is very quick and it has to
do with that dialogue the way that
dialogue is written is [ __ ] great
yeah it definitely is and like i said
it's real it's kind of like organic too
because even in the
scenes with the family uh you know roy's
family
where they're you know they're they're
talking in the foreground and then the
kids like banging a baby doll and
[ __ ] in the background and it's just
kind of like and another thing too that
i think steven spielberg talked about a
little bit
um with this movie was saying that
um he also was kind of trying to because
roy
he's like it was almost kind of like a
religious conversion or
somebody with like an artistic
temperament and
worrying that they can't reconcile their
artistic temperament or their religious
conversion or whatever
with a stable family life you know what
i mean because there was a lot of that
kind of [ __ ] going on in the movie too
where roy was like he saw the ufo and it
was like this amazing thing and he
became like obsessed with it and then
like his wife just didn't get
it and um you know she ended up like
taking off and taking the kids
now steven spielberg did say later he's
like i made this movie before i had
children of my own and he's like
nowadays i probably wouldn't have made
it
that i hate it when they [ __ ] do that
that roy had left
his kids behind like to go on the mother
ship
yeah but you know he's like i didn't
have kids at the time and that just
seemed like
yeah well you know that's that would
have been the reality of it
young guys were doing that yeah and i
hate it when these dudes kind of back up
off of their damn artistic geniuses when
they were young
now that's what the priorities of a
young man were yeah
and uh i remember i would have i'm from
that guy is like the generation my dad's
generation
they got married too young they all
divorced
trump that's really what that was about
you know
they were waking up to a larger truth
and they were like you know this really
isn't me
and they freaking all got divorced
there's a huge wave of it
that's where all this single parenthood
stuff that you have today it's
widespread
well it wasn't back in the 70s but that
was the beginning of it though
yeah because like you said i feel like
it was pretty common for people in the
50s and 60s
they were getting married at first
married in 1890 like just when they were
out of high school
right out of college right and they they
didn't know what they were doing they
were just doing it because that's where
their parents and their grandparents got
married like that
they weren't married on anything other
than just basically kind of like
convenience and physical attraction
really a lot of it for the girls was
convenience trying to get out of the
house
oh yeah big time because they were
living with their parents yeah so there
was no
people need to shake this [ __ ] you we
are all
people need to stop need to drop all
this [ __ ] high-minded [ __ ]
we were born because our parents were
[ __ ] that's all it was well yeah
everybody there's no deeper meaning to
it than that
all right that's all it was
and they were hooking up real young back
then because they wanted to get out of
the damn house
yeah that's all it was yeah so yeah they
got divorced
big [ __ ] deal it's not the end of the
world you know what i mean they
remarried later on and had more kids or
whatever but that's just the way
society's evolved and that's what
happened during that generation
so that's how i understood the whole
because look what happened he saw the
ufo
he was tripping yeah um the wife really
didn't get it didn't give a [ __ ] kind of
deal he was opening it up to a whole new
reality something that was
more yeah and i mean she didn't see it
she didn't see it and she was just kind
of like hey we've got these three
screaming children that
we have to take care of and like i can't
worry about that yeah and he's seeing
he's in a way seeing his old life as
drudgery that that wasn't
him and then he's he's embarking on this
new
adventure it's male liberation really
but
it's what it is he's embarking on
embarking on a new adventure especially
when he meets another woman
who's seen it now she's got a kid and
they kind of show kind of like a little
in a way like a a brief adoption of her
little kid where he's like he treats it
like he's little barry
little barry all right but then he says
[ __ ] it i'm going i'm going to outer
space and he leaves
she wasn't going to go back to him
anyway the wife no she took off she
thought he was crazy
so well he was doing some crazy it was
great to be fair the aliens were [ __ ]
with his mind
making sculptures out of mashed potatoes
throwing dirt in the windows
and making like
i mean i can see well the thing about it
i think like the older i've gotten
like um i can see both sides of it i
mean obviously from his point of view
you know he's like i saw this amazing
thing you know we're not alone blah blah
blah
and it's like you know he needs to do
something with that
uh and uh but i can see her side of it
too because she's just kind of like oh
my god this dude that i'm supposed to be
raising these kids with has gone
completely
mental and you know he's trashing the
house
and it's like you know what am i
supposed to do remember the aliens had
implanted something in their
subconscious they were calling them
yeah yeah yeah yeah he had been called
yeah
so he couldn't stay you know yeah
it's not even well it's weird because
not everybody that got called went
no i mean barry because he got taken but
he didn't
go in the end did he no they gave him
back yeah they gave him back they're
like yeah
he's too little he's too dirty he's
he's putting boogers all over everything
in the spacecraft
i think the message was is that he was
too little and they sent him back to his
mom
yeah they didn't take the mom yeah she's
good there too
so they just uh studied him for a little
bit but uh
no they it invited a bunch of people but
they couldn't make it because they were
either too old or not you know they
didn't have the physical prowess to make
it past
all those soldiers and all those [ __ ]
you know all those mental
tests like yeah poison gas you can't
come over here yeah
yeah the psyops they couldn't they
couldn't see through the psyops
but dreyfus could he goes there's
nothing wrong now he said that this is
[ __ ]
so there was nothing wrong with with
with well yeah because i mean the
the message that he got was so clear and
other people had it too
but i mean him and um him and that other
woman were kind of the only ones that
were
that got passed there was a you better
have your mask on theme
yeah i like that psyops well then the
other well the other guy
that went there was a third guy that
went with them like climbing to the top
of devil's tower
but then he got uh gas that didn't kill
him right yeah
it was just sleeping gas i just put him
to sleep that's what they did to all the
animals
yeah that's right to make all the
[ __ ] cows look dead that's right
knocked out for six yeah they said that
you woke up the bad hangover
yeah um yeah but it it's a it
it's still a masterpiece it stands up to
the test of time
i don't know how a younger viewer would
see it i
i think i think when we see it we see it
in the context of the time
um we see it from the context of the
late 70s and the 80s
before special effects were just some
you know
free basically where you can show any
image to anyone now
you know this one is practical effects
and the effects are
sparse there's not a whole lot of them
by today's standards well even by the
standards of the 80s there weren't that
many effects
interestingly spielberg's good though he
actually did
like some test reels of early cgi
for this yeah but he didn't really like
the way they looked
so what they did on this um the the
effects that you see like of the
spacecraft and everything like that
what they did was those were usually
miniatures or other things
but they shot all the effect shots on 70
millimeter
and then the rex the rest of the film
was shot in 35 millimeter
so that way you wouldn't you know when
you put them together
uh you wouldn't lose resolution because
we were kind of talking about this when
we were talking about some of the ray
harryhausen movies
especially like the third one you know
the eye of the tiger sinbad and the eye
of the tiger
where some of the shots that were
composited
uh you could see that they were lesser
resolution but spielberg specifically
did not want that to happen so the
special effects shots were shot at like
higher
resolution than the rest of the movie so
then when they were composited together
they would match
you know what i mean pepper said she was
born in 1990 and she loved the movie as
a kid
so that's that's good to know i mean i
liked the movie
when i was a kid because especially not
knowing how it was going to end
because it did build up suspense you
weren't sure whether or not the aliens
were a threat or not
like when they go get buried they're
coming down the chimney and you go
santa's coming
look there's santa and then yeah barry's
into
they're trying to come in they tried and
then not the screws started unscrewing
from the
from the you know the central air on the
floor yeah
screws started to come unsc unscrewed
like it was coming out
which is weird you know what i mean you
had i guess it was just some kind of
electromagnetic force coming through the
house
doing weird [ __ ] trying to get in there
to get barry
they were waiting for the doggy door
they really really wanted barry yeah
they pulled him out through the doggy
door using some kind of tractor bead
yeah but he was but he wasn't scared
though no he was his mom was freaking
out obviously as you would
but yeah you didn't know really through
the film like you kind of knew that they
probably
weren't a threat but they were doing
some things that seemed a little bit
threatening sometimes
yeah well they were jacking people's
minds and giving you visions and
abducted little kids and they were
giving back stuff it was spooky
sun came down it was beautiful it sagged
to me that's what the old mexican guy
said out in the desert
and there they were tripping over what
he said and then the lost [ __ ]
navy air flight was it flight 1919
flight 19 they gave all the planes back
which i think we did a show about they
were all brand new
they all still had the calendars and the
photographs in there
so they were have been keeping them in
some kind of temporal status
stasis
some one of the one of the observers
when they started letting go and the
crowd comes
when the when the crew comes out because
they haven't aged a bit i guess einstein
was right
that's not what that meant i mean you
know it didn't mean that they were
traveling around
they were all the same age as they were
when they were abducted so they were
somehow put frozen in time once they
were taken
yeah they must have put them in kind of
like a time
stopping capsule i don't think it would
freeze them they just
stop time around them when that way they
weren't aging very much
after they took them yeah that's how i
understood that because they would
bought if they're
if they were doing time dilation like
through einstein they would all be
different ages when they came back
right they weren't they were the same
age they were when they left so that
means times that was stopped for them
they were just like keeping them in
keeping them on ice in a certain way
they were in a tardis time wasn't
passing for them
it's like they were partying with aliens
though at that time well the aliens were
partying while they were kind of like
yeah because when they came out they
were all from different eras
yeah some of them were victorians and
stuff they weren't sure where they were
what the [ __ ] is going on here i was
just like you know going through my
worthless carriage and then all of a
sudden you were kind of nodding off one
of them that came out of there was a dog
yeah i remember i remember that one
before i've seen this movie before right
yeah so it's just kind of i was really
really sleepy and we just we drank a
beer or a couple of beers
and a beer always makes me really really
look like a white afghan came
walking out or a ship probably that dog
was probably just like what the [ __ ]
well yeah but what i was saying about
the special effects too is that a lot of
the [ __ ]
um like i think that to the couple
extraterrestrials at the end
you know the one that does the hand
signal like with the music and
everything
that was a puppet um the little bitty
extraterrestrials that surround like
richard dreyfuss and like take him on
the ship or whatever
those were all uh six-year-old girls
that's funny from them from the
elementary school near where they filmed
it in mobile alabama
um and they just put them all in little
alien suits yeah
they thought that [ __ ] was hilarious i
know they were like we get to be space
people
yeah it was all such a six-year-old yeah
i thought that was so funny
but yeah so the thing about this is that
this took a really long time like steven
spielberg kept
like tinkering with it there were so
there were so many production problems
not so much
because of the crew but because um
steven spielberg said that
he's like the last 25 minutes of this
were like the most difficult film that i
ever edited because i couldn't
he's like we just went through hundreds
and hundreds of feet of footage because
i was looking for like the perfect shots
you know what i mean like to edit it
to kind of get this amazing like epic
ending and he wasn't quite happy with it
but columbia pictures who had backed it
who was who were actually in financial
trouble at the time
and actually didn't really have the
money to give him for this they had to
borrow it from some other studios and
[ __ ]
uh hoping that it would be a big success
which it was
uh luckily for them but um so
they they were like well we have to get
this movie out like in 1977 and he
wanted to
delay it until summer of 1978 so he
could get the cut exactly the way he
wanted it
and they were just like no no we have to
do it right now so he got it put it out
but then in 1980 columbia said
okay you can re-release it the way you
want it but with the stipulation that
you have to put in
scenes inside the spaceship and stephen
didn't want to do that because he's like
i wanted to keep it a mystery
like i like to keep it ambiguous but
they were like well that's the only way
he's like because we need something else
so we can resell it
you know because we're re-releasing it
so we want something like that people
have already seen it
so there'll be something different dom
dom is
he's saying that basically he was born
in 81.
he saw alien and uh what he says
alien and predator okay before
seeing close encounters yeah so when he
saw of course encounters it felt too
1970s ish and and he really didn't give
it much of a chance he didn't really
think much about it which
yeah i think the context the time and
the order in which things came out
had a lot to do with it close encounters
i think was the first movie i ever saw
about aliens i saw it in the theater my
dad took me to see it
and then later alien one yeah
and excuse me now later star wars yeah
well star wars and this came out this
same year
yeah okay then star wars i think i saw
after this
and then i think alien one came out
after this after that
yeah that was 79. and when you saw him
in that order you saw two friendly
movies about
you saw this one which was cool and then
star wars which even topped it
you know it topped it oh yeah that was
the ultimate space movie
and then your dad takes you to see alien
alien and you and and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you up oh [ __ ] the chest bursters
and these [ __ ] monsters i thought the
aliens were yeah
see yeah it was [ __ ] badass but
well the thing about it though is that
the thing yeah
well the thing about it though is that
throughout the 50s and 60s
most of the you know alien the sci-fi
movies had been they had been hostile
not all of them there were a few that
the aliens were friendly and then like
we killed them because we thought they
were hostile
so but this one was actually one of the
big ones where
the aliens coming to earth even though
initially their
you know their motive wasn't clear maybe
it was kind of threatening
but it ended up being like a really cool
like awesome experience and everybody
was
like super into it so it was like a
really positive you know it was like the
aliens coming to earth and being hey
you guys are finally cool enough to like
[ __ ] hang with us
yeah and it's kind of one of few movies
that's like that really and then i feel
like after this came out then it went
all like hostile hands again
khan says the first movie about aliens
he ever saw
was uh alien one he was eight he says
you can imagine what that happened there
yeah i can't imagine seeing that as an
eight-year-old yeah i would have
yeah i still would have loved it i was
uh see what year did it come out in the
70s
79
79 yes so i was nine oh
the same i [ __ ] loved it loved it but
it scared the [ __ ] out of me
well you wanted to see it again it's a
scary movie yeah i wanted to see it
again
afterwards well they want to see it
again i had to take a rest
you know what i mean i was proud that i
made it through that movie
oh thought about it for like about
four or five days and and i said let's
see it again
and my dad took me to see it again well
i was you know i was the same when i was
can i love scary [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's like even if it would just keep me
awake all night because like i said i
saw some pretty scary movies when i was
seven or eight years old and they scared
the crap out of me and they gave me
nightmares and stuff
but i liked that yeah i think a lot of
kids like scary [ __ ] yeah
oh i loved it yeah you're like proud
that you made made it through
yeah survived it made it i made it
maybe that's what turned maybe that's
why it turned out the way i did
i made it throw yourself into some bad
[ __ ]
yeah i made it i made it it's like a
thrill-seeking type of deal
it is yeah probably it is yeah yeah um
yeah captain blairno says jay allen
highneck of project
blue book made an appearance if i
remember correctly yes he did uh he was
the guy with the pipe
and uh also esther mentioned that i
wanted to mention this too that yes
francois truffaut probably better known
as a
very famous french film director was
also in this movie
he did some acting and stuff as well i
think this was the last movie that he
acted in
but yeah he played uh lacombe so he was
in the first scene he was the french guy
the dude that played bishop from alien 2
is in the movie but you don't notice him
he's standing in the crowd he was one of
the crowd at the end like when the
mothership lands because we were like
he's maybe 32 maybe i couldn't believe
it
yeah standing back there and they go
look who that is look look look yeah i
was like holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah i didn't i didn't remember him
being in that yeah
um yeah gram there's hammer says the
spaceships buzzing around in close
encounters sure resemble the ufos the
navy pilots have been seeing just saying
yeah well this like i said steven
spielberg
um was super super into aliens and he
i think he believes in like all that ufo
stuff you know what i mean like he
thinks that
they've been visiting and all that i
mean as far as i can determine so
he was like super jazzed to make this
and honestly he was gonna make it
earlier like i said but then
he did jaws and the fact that he did
jaws and jaws did so well
like let him make this movie because
they wanted him to make this other
kind of like big adventure movie kind of
like jaws was or like a horror movie
and he was like no no i want to do like
this kind of and you know
this kind of like you know cool like ufo
sci-fi movie and the studios weren't
like super jazzed about it
he actually i think he pitched it as it
was only gonna cost like three million
dollars to make
but it ended up costing like 19 and a
half million
but luckily it made like 300 million so
it was fine louie said that i thought
some kick-ass movies when i was a kid
said yeah i did i was lucky i was born
at the right time
and most guys who are really real
students of uh
of film who are my age that saw the same
movies
i saw will say that we grew up
during the golden age the second golden
era of hollywood
that there was just a bunch of good
movies all came out in the
late 70s all the way really
really mid 90s i think i would even go
earlier than i would say like even
60s 70s i mean i don't know
young to see him though yeah that's true
i think it started with
i i think it really the new era started
with like
lucas and spielberg yeah they kicked a
lot of [ __ ] off because
they were not big hollywood and the same
thing
same thing with uh francis ford coppola
and
uh you know some of the people who
worked with um
um what's what's the italian movie
the guy who did flash gordon that's
theater that that the dino dealer
dilo de laurentiis that that studio too
did some fantastic [ __ ]
and it was kind of like they just had
enough
technology to where small studios could
now have decent special effects
and you had some good writers and uh it
was all kind of culminating and the guys
that were making the cool [ __ ] that we
talk about now
those guys really weren't deep in the
studio system they were almost kind of
like
semi um privateer directors you know
what do you call them um
in indy they were kind of semi-indie
then they ended up became
coming mainstream over time just because
they're shipping so much money just
because their [ __ ] made so much fun
so it was like a new wave of into and i
almost want to say maybe it started with
um um
what was george lucas's first movie with
about the the hot rodders [ __ ]
kind of happy days ripped it off what
american graffiti american graffiti
i remember when that thing came out it
had people
people really liked it it had a big
response
and maybe you were a little girl but i
remember personally people talking about
i remember people talking about it about
them like it was like a great movie i
saw it later and it was just it was just
a good movie
but you know but i think in context of
the time there weren't very many movies
like that right i think that's something
that you have to think of any time you
watch a movie for me it's like you have
to
you know what was normal normal for the
con you need like context sure
that movie was almost kind of like a
reality movie yeah for the time like a
slice of lifetime
yeah it was really good so i think i
think i was lucky to see these when they
were coming out in the theater
yeah i don't think it will happen again
i think the theater's over
it it's run its course the future will
all be
[ __ ] on streaming but it's always t
cutting edge technology
that's no longer film i mean that's 20th
century [ __ ] it's gonna be these video
games
video games will go down in the minds of
these young peoples i remember when that
game came out
remember when red dead when you know
when you know didn't count this
what's that cowboy game when this cowboy
came came out remember when [ __ ]
fallout 76
came out you know it's gonna be like
that yeah probably
that's what's gonna be we'll be dead by
then
but you know what i feel that way about
certain video games i remember
goldeneye off n64 i want that on my
[ __ ] xbox one
did i want to play gold tonight the only
one i could play is damn
perfect dark yeah which is kind of a
it's the same engine
uh also like
[ __ ] arcania of time or ocarina of
time that real [ __ ]
zelda game yeah that when that came out
that was just [ __ ] great i can play
those old games and
they're it's nostalgic they're they're
still playable
you know so in a way that's like a movie
yeah so i was kind of i didn't really
get super into gaming back then
i liked you know castlevania and metroid
and stuff like that and zelda
yeah but metroid didn't age real well
though it's not as playable
they weren't 3d yeah yeah as soon as it
made the leap into 3d
like on the n64 some of the very first
like shadows of the empire
which is an old star wars game that was
3d uh uh [ __ ] doom
and those are all real playable
i got some of the old dooms you know
doom one two doom two
doom 94 or whatever it is or 97 or
and you can still go through them and
play them they're fun and
it's like watching an old movie it's a
movie-like experience in a way
yeah you know what i mean yeah look when
you see a movie you get a certain
feeling of it you know what i mean
yeah like that especially goldeneye
007 golden eye yeah yeah i've just seen
other people
play it like man i want to play that
game
you can think you might play it on pc
though yeah kind of oxlon says laser
blast anyone
yeah yeah that was the one with the
turtles turtle aliens with butt
pods yeah which was a strange choice for
puppets but okay
yeah that was on mystery science theater
so i've seen it lots of times
uh oh i also i wanted to mention too
that douglas trumbull
was the visual effects supervisor on
close encounters
and he was also doing the visual effects
of the cinematography or whatever on the
andromeda strain which we talked about
yesterday
and that was a total total accident that
we did that small world isn't it
so uh do you have anything else you
wanted to say about close encounters
it's just
it it held up pretty well the movie held
up pretty well
yeah like i said it's not my favorite
spielberg but um it's probably
i don't know until he did um until he
did um
what the [ __ ] no i can't even remember
what that movie was that which we did
later the
the nazi concentration camp one uh
anderson schindler's list thank you
jesus christ i couldn't think of that
until he did schindler's list i think
this was probably like his most
personal film like his kind of passion
project and i think other than
this and maybe a.i i think these are the
only ones that he actually
wrote and directed you know what i mean
i think it was because i think like a
couple other dudes like took a crack at
his idea like at the script
but i think he ended up writing it
because it wasn't coming out the way he
wanted
so you know and like i said he had kind
of final cut but
i think that what i from what i could
determine
of all the different versions they're
called different things we watched the
director's cut
but i think the collector's cut or
collector's edition or something is the
closest to what he wanted he said
i got i bought the 4k um
blu-ray with a 4k and a blu-ray it's uh
i think it was 20 bucks and it comes
with a
a third disc that has extras on it i
haven't seen yet
i think it was 20 bucks it was worth it
um
i don't have a 4k player but i probably
will a 4k tv i'll probably have one
i mean eventually eventually you know
but um
for the money you know you just spend
extra two bucks and you get all those
extras
that'd be the way to go it does hold up
if you if you're nostalgic for the movie
if you liked it you saw your kid it's
worth watching
and i had forgotten how funny yeah
richard dreyfuss was
if you've never seen it it's worth
watching yeah
yeah i mean he's a great character like
it's just
like watching him like to play with the
trains with his kids shrieking in the
background it's just
no i don't know it was just something
really funny to me you'll never really
capture the spirit of 1977.
this is this movie is the first time the
ufo
phenomenon is talked about from this
point of view with seriousness so it was
kind of like a very big deal it was a
movie like this later on you had other
[ __ ] coming out like signs
and you know it's it's commonplace now
these kind of themes but not in 77
this is like it was either a sci-fi
movie with [ __ ] flying saucers or war
of the worlds
or it was um something like the old
version of the thing
or some cheap things where you're being
attacked by a rug monster
you know exactly what i'm talking about
well yeah because i just watched that
the other day
the creeping terror i'm looking at you
black and white
[ __ ] 1950s teenagers running running
away from a goddamn
carpet out in the woods out back it was
it was like
five or six people under a carpet yeah
with like kind of a front
and i thought it was really funny
because this monster eats people
but the people kind of have to crawl
into its mouth for that to happen
because yeah that's usually what you're
dealing with
so you could like i said mst did it they
were just like if you could help me out
by crawling in here thanks
you could tell that's exactly what was
going on it's like a bunch of people
under a bunch of rugs it's so [ __ ]
funny
all right let's move on to red dawn yeah
yeah red dawn 1984.
i saw this when it came out uh
i was i i liked it when it came out but
i wasn't like super impressed with it at
the time
i just thought it was just another
cheesy kind of 80s
actiony type movie with patrick swayze
and
who else was entitled mr tiger blood
tiger blood charlie sheen charlie sheen
see thomas howell
yeah jennifer gray yeah leah
leah thompson yeah although this was
right before she did back to the future
yeah and um
it's about world war three the united
states gets invaded by
communist forces it's like they get
invaded by cuba
venezuela and i think honduras with the
soviet union backing them up
and they take a pretty good part of the
united states
before they the attack stalls out
and there's like an occupied zone
inside the occupied zone or some
teenagers who
uh kind of survive and become like a
band of
rebels to fight the
communist occupation of wolverines yeah
of part of the united states
i didn't know it at the time this is
john millius movie he directed it
[ __ ] produced it too well he the
thing about it is this is
actually originally it was not his
script okay um
there was a guy i think his name was
kevin some kevin mccarthy or something
like that
and interestingly his idea for this
movie originally was supposed to be like
kind of this gritty
uh indie film about it was
supposed to be i think it was a soviet
invasion of the united states but it was
supposed to be about
kids not teenagers um i think it was
called ten
soldiers or something ten soldiers i
think it was called and it was a bunch
of kids and they were gonna fight back
against it but then they would start
turning against each other so it was
gonna be like a lord of the flies
type of thing yeah um but the studio was
like okay well we bought that script but
he's like no let's make it like teenage
rambo
instead uh at which point they gave it
to john milius
yeah and uh he sort of like sort of
rewrote it and [ __ ]
although the way it came out he was like
i
from what i could determine like some of
the quotes that i read about it he's
like it kind of went in a direction that
he didn't like
love anymore but you know what i mean
yeah
it's what's a good way to
it's worth revisiting it's worth
watching if you've never seen it
it it it's a good watch it was an
expensive movie
all practical effects they blew up so
they blew up a lot of [ __ ] for this
movie
this is in a time when you could you
couldn't get your hands on anything
soviet
so they had to mock up american tanks to
look like soviet tanks
yeah and helicopters to look like soviet
helicopters and try to make it look like
a hind helicopter
um they blow a lot of [ __ ] up
they knock a lot of [ __ ] over
[Laughter]
it's got it's got it the story is kind
of basic
but what milius did is he's tried to
tell the story in an
epic way as if it's an epic legendary
tale of [ __ ] legendary heroes
and it's also kind of a little bit like
a how-to manual very much like what
conan
one was except it was in a little bit
more modern terms
there it's kind of it's kind of
lesson based each character kind of
uh has certain attributes and they show
you what happens to you
if you're like that um which is kind of
cool that's kind of the way conan was
uh it's not as epic or elegant as conan
no way yeah i i mean i had seen it when
i was a kid
like you know i saw it when it came out
or the year after care of the year it
came to cable whatever so i was probably
like a teenager
and i didn't love it i was just kind of
like oh okay whatever like i think my
brother kind of liked it more because
he's like oh yeah he stopped blowing up
but then i didn't i never really watched
it again so like watching it again it's
like
inelegant is a good way of putting it
yeah it's not an illness like the
editing is kind of clunky and i feel
like there wasn't really
i didn't realize that like the invasion
starts like
immediately yeah so you don't really get
a lot of time with the characters before
the invasion to sort of get to know them
um
it's just pretty much the invasion
happens and then it just goes from set
piece to set piece
i'm gonna say it wouldn't help you know
why because the characters are not
realistic each one is an epic archetype
that's true so there's nothing to know
that
each one is almost like something out of
the bible here's ham
here's abraham you know what i mean
here's lot here's cain
they're they're already archetypes
okay the son of the politician is the
traitor
what happens to the traitor he's killed
by his own friend
yeah justice served okay the other guy
his parents killed by the communists
he's fueled by hatred
everything every person he kills he
[ __ ] make puts his notches on his
belt
an experienced soldier says boy that
[ __ ] hatred is going to burn you up
he kills a lot of enemies in the end he
decides to challenge a hind helicopter
which blows him into [ __ ] bits that's
a lesson
yeah you know if you hate can fuel you
to kill a lot of enemies but it'll also
fuel you to
[ __ ] attack something you have no
chance of [ __ ] some dumb [ __ ]
yeah everything's like that you know
what i mean
um there's girls but
they get mad when you they get mad when
you tell them to wash dishes
they say we're more than that we can
fight too so they become they become
fighters so they're both kind of like uh
uh they're both kind of like what was
valeria
one of them tried to be like valeria
from conan
remember and get with the pilot yeah but
he got killed because i will never love
anyone again
and a guy and the other guy says well if
you don't love anybody there's no reason
for you to be
be here on this planet anymore later on
a few
scenes later she's [ __ ] cut down by a
helicopter
you didn't notice all that stuff yeah
yeah it's all
very kind of
aesop's fable based you know
uh which is not bad that's milius being
amelia's he's trying to do like i get
that but you know i've seen
some of his other movies which were like
you said a lot more elegantly yes
told this one is a little bit but you
can see that
this i mean one the script it wasn't his
original idea and
it's nothing like what it was originally
conceived as um
and so he was kind of handed it later
yeah because they're like hey he does
all those war movies and stuff like give
him that
and uh so he kind of sort of tried to
put it in the way but
i don't know i kind of feel like uh
somebody mentioned earlier that um
that yeah patrick swayze and jennifer
gray were in this and then they were
both in
um dirty dancing three years later and i
heard i don't know if this is true or
not but i heard that they kind of hated
each other
um because they met on this move on red
dawn and then they hated each other and
then it'd work again
it on dirty dancing and i think that
when patrick swayze got cast and they
were gonna cast jennifer gray he's like
oh hell no
he's like i don't like that chick i
don't know why i don't know why he had
such thing against her i don't know if
that's true or not that's just what i
heard
but um i don't know i kind of feel like
i don't know i thought that the acting
in this was not
all that good like even for the era
charlie sheen was good
um this it just seems a little
i never thought patrick swayze was a
good actor he's good in something i
never really
he always just seemed like patrick
swayze to me like yeah that's true
he does he does have a swayze like
quality uh the guy who played the
[ __ ] f-15
pilot i thought was the best well
power's booth is rad i mean he's in a
he played jim jones in a movie yeah he
was there to class up the joint
yeah oh big time um even though he
wasn't the original choice but you know
and then another another like little
mini story arc that they did was
is that the honduran guy
was bitching about being an occupation
force he was like you know
back when i was young i was a partisan i
was f i was a rebel fighting against
these oppression now you're making me
become
be a policeman over these people so he
became what he hated
and in the end he let patrick swayze i
call him patricia let the rebels go
patrick what was his character named jed
right
jed yeah yeah i mean it was
it was not an elegant movie but it's not
a bad movie what
dated it and what kind of [ __ ] it up
was their very 80s style gun fights
that are totally unrealistic they run
out into the middle of the road and duke
it out with like 40 or 50 armed men who
are behind cover
with assault rifles all right and
they're they're beating them
no you get cut to shreds you get they're
they're doing [ __ ] that's not
that's just not possible well i feel
like the way that they
uh staged the gun battle
yeah made it look very implausible very
important that this group of teenagers
could have ever done this
could have beat like these whole like
big [ __ ] battalions of
dude yeah in one scene they get spotted
by
three hind d helicopters which are like
the soviets version of a troop transport
slash attack helicopter they got a
cannon on them and wire guided missiles
they can carry troops they get spotted
by these things
and they elude these three helicopters
they basically run
from them on horseback
and then one of them i was in the
bathroom and he came out i came out
you can't run away from no you came away
from helicopters
no way to escape a helicopter if hell's
got
yeah if you escape if if you're spotted
by a [ __ ] helicopter you're dead
it you can't run it will follow you
wherever you go
if you go into a tunnel it blows the
[ __ ] mouth of the tunnel open uh
it blows and you die in a [ __ ]
avalanche in a cave collapse if you run
into a building
it [ __ ] destroys the entire damn
building you cannot run from a
helicopter
it sees you it kills you it just did a
story
you know yeah so some of this stuff like
i said that's not a real it's
you know there were a lot of movies like
this that came out in the 80s that were
just these really like over-the-top
i mean that was kind of like why a lot
of people like those 80s action movies
because they're really like over the top
and not
not all that realistic and it's just
like a bunch of [ __ ]
uh blowing up and also the the theme too
of just like a bunch of plucky
youngsters fighting back against like a
much larger i think that was like
another kind of recurring theme
yeah so yeah and another thing is that
they do something called [ __ ]
and uh well they do something called
close ambush
which is where you get on a road on the
high ground
behind cover and wait for your [ __ ]
targets to come through
you blow the claymore mines take out the
front vehicle in the back vehicle to
keep them all trapped
and then you engage all the targets
which is all the dudes in there
well they did this to like a formation
of three trucks
carrying infantry and about 60 dudes
spilled out of that
those trucks and ran on the other side
of the truck where the claymore mines
were
because that's what you do wherever the
wherever the cover is
on the other side of that [ __ ] target
it's called the other side of that kill
zone
that's where you're going to put mines
when you
initiate this ambush on the troops they
have the same training you have
they know that if they jump out of that
truck and go into the
downhill that the mines are there they
don't do that
what they do is they run straight at you
guns blazing all of them because that's
their only chance to get out of the kill
zone
so they show six kids light weaponry one
bell fed
weapon kill about probably about 40 or
50
armed infantry it's not possible the way
they showed it
it's not possible but like i said that
was kind of a theme of these 80s movies
just like oh the little guy
fighting back and he's able to like take
out all of these you know what i mean
they didn't even take casualties and
they had no training it's that that's
just something they figured out on their
own
no that was another thing too they
didn't even have like a training montage
in this [ __ ]
and it was just kind of like suddenly a
month later they know how to do their
they know how to do all this because
they were hunters their dads showed them
how to hunt no it doesn't work that way
well yeah those are two completely
different skills
yeah sniper maybe but not not a
professional hunter or not a
professional soldier
yeah that's like i said that's
completely different yeah they were
using rpgs
yeah and [ __ ] and claymore mines and
yeah there's a little instruction
booklet in there it's all visual
you can be illiterate and see what the
instructions are
some of it's written on the side or
inside the [ __ ] bags that the minds
come in
but you as a civilian wouldn't really
know how to deploy that
yeah without even without somebody
giving you the idea hey put these in
wherever the troops are going to run to
for cover
you just don't think that way until
somebody says that
yeah you know that was something that
they learned by experience and they
the experience they gained experience by
getting their by getting their own guys
killed
people die you learn from it and then
you adapt so it's not something
that somebody with no experience thinks
of because they haven't been shot at or
killed yet
right yeah slasher fred says one of my
favorite movies with jennifer gray is
ferris bueller's day off i agree she was
great in that
because she was playing kind of a [ __ ]
uh louis says ron superfly o'neill was
also in it
which is weird because i'm pretty sure
that guy was also in
when a stranger calls which is the movie
that we're doing for the retrospective
this week
and again we didn't even mean to do that
yeah see look everything's coming
together
fourth drawer down says in reality being
a member of the resistance would be
suicide yes it would
yeah there was really wasn't that many
of them i kind of thought i mean and did
this happen because i kind of dozed off
a couple times because
even like a bunch of stuff blowing up
gets like boring after a while
so i was kind of like i was really
sleepy because like i said beer so i
kept like
dozing off and i was kind of like well
wouldn't there be
was there a point where the wolverines
didn't like people that they liberated
from some of the campuses
like did they join them or was it always
there that's what i mean
because you think that that's what would
happen that they would you know
they would at least get some more like
recruits yeah that didn't happen
and uh it was it showed a very
glorious kind of
they're trying kind of showed a little
bit what what was happening in
afghanistan against the soviets back in
the
70s and 80s but that wouldn't happen in
the united states
because the afghans were doing that
against the soviet union because the
united states was back there [ __ ]
supporting them and there were special
forces with them that were training them
and pushed them to do that
most of the time when you have a
situation like they showed these
wolverines in
they would be doing missions like the
very very first one where they're up in
the woods and they see three guys taking
photographs and joking around by their
vehicle you jump on them and kill them
you always go where the weakest target
is you don't go over the strong targets
you go for the weakness get your ass
shut off yeah all right
most civil wars most wars of resistance
are not rebels fighting armies no no no
no no no that's just what you saw on
television they don't want to tell you
the truth
the real truth is is it's rebels
fighting the normies
you got one army telling you the
civilians how to act you got the rebel
army punishing the civilians for obeying
so
what the wolverines really would have
been doing is going to like
american people's houses and saying you
sided with the soviets you subsided with
the commies and
and then you go out there and you kill
him and then [ __ ] leave him leave his
head sitting on the front porch
and write the word traitor above it and
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to make it so
this the normies or the civilians cannot
side with the soviets
if if they do they [ __ ] die that's
what
all these isis guys and all these rebels
and [ __ ]
terrorists you call them terrorists they
call themselves just
fighters you know that's what they're in
in iran and what they're doing is they
were going after other iranians
excuse me in iraq they were going after
other iraqis presiding with the
americans
that's what most of it is 99 of it
well yeah because like it's you know i
fight that army what yeah
there's only like [ __ ] six of you
yeah it's civilian versus civilian
it's not civilian versus army dom the
bomb is talking a couple people have
mentioned
uh near dark yes we want i want to
actually review that one of these days
because that's a really good like kind
of underrated uh vampire movie
and uh i think i put it on the list a
couple times but it never won the poll
but we'll eventually get to it because
yeah that's definitely one that i've
been wanting to do for a long time
um so yeah what else do we have to say
about
red dawn anything um a decent movie
but you have to understand the
limitations of the time
um is it one of is it is it one of
milius's best
[ __ ] no yeah i found it a little cheesy
no yeah
you uh actually it's a lot tv you want
to see
apocalypse now which which he was
involved in that
and uh you want to see conan one and you
want to see jeremiah johnson
well yeah those are those are his those
some of the best movies that he's done
i mean you could kind of tell that this
one wasn't his
like a project that he was like really
really passionate about
jeremiah johnson is gorgeous that is an
elegant [ __ ] badass movie about a
dude surviving up in the mountains
uh trying and trying to get along with
the indians he ends up in a personal
war against the crow the crow indians
that's a good [ __ ] movie eating some
livers along liver eating [ __ ]
the only man to literally kill a
[ __ ] with another [ __ ]
cut a dude's leg off and beat the other
dude to death with the leg and then
nod on the frozen leg all the way
walking home
over a hundred and something miles i
love him that's livery
came up against him he [ __ ] he was
cannibal he was cannibal
yeah but they don't discuss that in in
in
in the movie jeremiah john they don't
mention he was gamble
but what that's like the coolest thing
about him or like the most interesting
thing
well you know he married an indian woman
he went engine what they call
it and indians ate each other's livers
for strength and
bravery you know and to desecrate the
[ __ ] dead enemies
you know you had to go to the happy
hunting grounds without your liver
i mean you know you might as well
because hey freeze terror tactics
you know come up against me i'll [ __ ]
eat you after you're dead then you know
go to heaven without your liver
it makes a lot of sense see and they're
like a [ __ ] with that dude he'll you
know
i'll cut off your leg and beat you with
it yeah
but they were captured and they were
going to sell him to another tribe
it's just i love i love the visual of
that of just like you having a leg
like cutting somebody sliding on a bunch
of [ __ ] yeah
like i said killing a [ __ ] with
another [ __ ] millions was real
good about getting involved in movies
that involved badassery that's why they
drove him out of hollywood they was like
oh no we're not having this anymore
red dawn actually got him kicked out of
hollywood evidently
but uh which is dumb because the studio
wanted it to be like that anyway i mean
like i said it was supposed to be like
an anti-war movie that they started
they're like no no make it like rambo
but with teenagers
yeah um but like even more over the top
and
that's what they did yeah now the big
lebowski is another good
movie and one of the one of the
characters in the big lebowski evidently
was
with was was it it was modeled after
milius that that's who they're talking
about if you see any john millius's
um uh interviews you you see it directly
you go yeah that's him that's it that's
exactly what
that's exactly what he was like loved
military [ __ ]
yeah shut the [ __ ] up donny yes
i wanted to join the french foreign
legion wanted to join the [ __ ]
israeli defense force he wanted to
[ __ ] join the usr but he couldn't you
know he was uh he had some kind of
medical problem i forgot it was
yeah i thought we talked about that one
day but i forgot what it was about what
it was
was he a diabetic or something oh yeah
better
it's either a diabetic or something
somebody might remember you had some
kind of medical problem you wouldn't let
him join
yeah oh well what are you gonna do yeah
all right so we've been going on for
over an hour
yeah it's worth seeing it's just
understand that it's not what amelia's
best
yeah i mean i think a lot of people it
has like a huge cult following
yeah um particularly people that are
really into like 80s action movies
yeah it's like it's an 80s action movie
yeah and like i said it's cheesy it's
over the top
it's the reason that it's not as fun i
think is some of the other over-the-top
ones is because it takes itself too
seriously
it does have some uh mythological epic
themes
yeah going through certain certain
characters things you can learn from
but they're not deep meaning they're not
real
super deep and super meaningful once
you're you know
older than 25. yeah but you do recognize
what it is they're talking about
yeah you know louis says he has asthma
asthma that's what it is so there you go
yeah you're never going to be able to be
anything involved with combat
and he wanted to either be a pilot he
wanted to either be a pilot or some kind
of airborne he wanted to join the
airborne
infantry or a ranger he wanted to do the
focus you know that's my [ __ ] though
no that's that's not never getting into
half i had a friend with that yeah
can't be trusted you need to be a good
dude all of a sudden asthma attack hits
you in the middle of a [ __ ]
firefight and doesn't get killed because
you can't fight and they're dependent on
you
i mean it sucks but because you want
good dudes in there but
you can't go into a combat mos with
[ __ ] asthma you have to probably go
into a support mos yeah because you
never know when that's gonna you can't
be doing something dangerous and then
have that [ __ ]
right no and if you imagine if that
happened byu were [ __ ] flying a
[ __ ]
f-15 and you know what i mean in a
[ __ ]
fire fight in dogfight now yeah that
would suck a lot
all right so anything else you would
like to add no that's it
anything else anybody would like to add
all right
so i guess well it's tuesday today right
yeah all right so we're doing the uh
sidetrack show
tomorrow evening at 5 p.m which is
always fun
so you know come by have a drink with us
we'll talk about whatever the hell we
feel like talking about i don't know
what we're going to talk about we never
know what we're going to talk about
we'll figure it out same time as you
guys figure it out but yeah uh
thanks everybody for dropping by today
have a good rest of your afternoon
and we will talk to you guys again
tomorrow evening
bye